buona sera tocca a me era un per il
ghiaccio rilasciate anche me iniziare
riconoscendo il coraggio anzi lasciatemi
dire il fegato di chi ha voluto portare
un evento di sapore globale in una
miniera di zolfo nel cuore della sicilia
gentile presentazione mi hanno fatto ma
io non sono un calciatore non sono un
attore non sono una rockstar e quindi è
solo salutare che a voi della mia vita
personale non ve ne importa
assolutamente nulla
anche così
lasciatemi raccontare qualcosa che mi è
successo
qualche anno fa mi è arrivata una
proposta strana mi hanno chiesto di
diventare il presidente dell'alleanza
globale delle isole delle nazioni unite
e la proposta è veramente strana perché
questa alleanza che si occupa di
difendere questi fragili territori
rispetto alla minaccia del cambiamento
climatico
non conta membri come
favignana all isola d'elba e fanno male
dovrebbero entrarci
i membri si chiamano kiribati tuvalu
tung ha nulla a che vedere con l'italia
ma allora perché a chiederlo un italiano
che per ragioni molto più nostrane le
alpi mi ritrovavo già fare il presidente
dell'alleanza globale delle nazioni
unite delle montagne e in quel contesto
li ululava all'assemblea generale delle
nazioni unite nelle coop per difendere i
ghiacciai
perché se si è isole è veramente isole
si sa che nessuno è un'isola la sventura
delle isole comincia con la fusione dei
ghiacciai in montagna è quella che fa
aumentare
il livello del mare e quindi si
riconosce che se si vuole sopravvivere
come isole dobbiamo far sopravvivere
anche le montagne
noi siamo in un momento cruciale entro
pochi anni se non facciamo la cosa
giusta cerchiamo ad avere un pianeta
invivibile passiamo in un momento
cruciale anche in positivo perché
finalmente abbiamo capito delle cose che
per molti anni per millenni abbiamo
ignorato
abbiamo capito che dipendiamo tutti
l'uno dall'altro ma soprattutto abbiamo
capito di cosa è fatta questa
interconnessione che ci lega tutti in
realtà che fossimo tutti legati lo
sapevamo da tempo
però la maniera in cui ci sembrava di
essere legati è stata sintetizzata da un
detto coniato dai nostri avi i romani
che hanno detto mors tua vita mea questo
è il nostro istinto se io voglio
guadagnare tu devi perdere se io voglio
vivere tu devi morire
beh non è vero
il legame montagne isole ce lo dimostra
e ci rendiamo conto di come non sia vero
se smettiamo di guardare solo noi stessi
il nostro ombelico e ci riferiamo a
questo meraviglioso equilibrio in cui
abitiamo che si chiama biosfera è una
questione di equilibrio ma nessuno si
occupa dell'equilibrio ci sono giornate
in cui ci facciamo dei propositi
tipicamente giorno del compleanno a
capodanno però a meno che fra di voi non
ci sia un buddista zen sarei molto
sorpreso che a capodanno si propone di
essere in equilibrio i nostri obiettivi
sono diversi crescere spandersi
migliorare arricchirsi e ci sembra che
l'equilibrio stessa qualcosa di statico
che ci frena e ci dimentichiamo che
senza equilibrio tutte queste cose che
ci stanno a cuore non sono raggiungibili
immaginatevi che io sia un ragazzo e che
a capodanno mi dò il proposito di
diventare un calciatore migliore mi
faccio una serie di schemi di
allenamento l'equilibrio non ci penso
proprio finché non mi viene a mancare mi
rompo il femore non ho più l'equilibrio
fisiologico allora sì mi rendo conto di
quanto vale
ecco questa essenzialità dell'equilibrio
vale anche nel rapporto che abbiamo fra
tutti noi e con il pianeta che ci ospita
perché perché la biosfera in cui
abitiamo fondamentalmente è un contesto
caotico governato dall effetto farfalla
il battito delle ali di una farfalla
tokyo l'avete sentito dire può essere il
primo evento di una serie di eventi che
può creare
un uragano in florida
questo è il carattere fondamentale della
biosfera ma se la biosfera fosse solo
effetto farfalla fosse solo
caotica non sarebbe biosfera la vita non
può vivere nella assoluta
imprevedibilità e anche la società umana
non può esistere organizzata
nell'assoluta imprevedibilità questa
county cita è imbrigliata da cicli
prevedibili del comportamento della
natura che sono proprio quello che ci
porta l'equilibrio non ci sarebbe
agricoltura se non è possibile prevedere
quando piove ma non è solo qualcosa che
riguarda i nostri antenati delle
campagne anche oggi il gestore
dell'acquedotto di milano non può
prevedere non può pianificare la
gestione dell'acqua se non la minima
idea di quando sono
innevate le alpi e assolutamente senza
re l'equilibrio pure noi gli diamo
valore perché per la stessa ragione per
cui siamo disposti a pagare 1.000
dollari un'oncia d'oro ma un uncia di
area quella che respiriamo siamo
disposti a pagarla 0 eppure se ci danno
la scelta finale polo o aria dobbiamo
scegliere l'aria in pratica non diamo
valore alle cose secondo la loro
obiettivo utilità ma secondo una
percezione di scarsità e allora non
diamo valore all'equilibrio
semplicemente perché madre natura ci ha
inondato di equilibrio salvo casi meno
fortunati nasciamo inondati di
equilibrio fisiologico e psicologico e
anche nel nostro rapporto col pianeta
l'equilibrio c'è venuto in soccorso ci
ha consentito di essere società
organizzate sapendo che la primavera
sboccerà in quel periodo perché se non
lo sapessimo non potremmo quando diciamo
degrado ambientale diciamo aumento della
dose di caos a discapito della dose di
equilibrio del
pianeta
quello che stiamo facendo a distruggere
l'equilibrio ma mi direte queste sono
previsioni chissà se sarà così guardiamo
al passato
per renderci conto di quanto sia
importante il riequilibrio in questa
nostra zona il mediterraneo siamo stati
inondati di equilibrio più che in altre
zone perché la grande massa d'acqua a è
servita come stabilizzatore delle
fluttuazioni e non è un caso che proprio
da noi sia nata la rivoluzione più
importante della storia umana la
rivoluzione agricola e quella che ci ha
fatto passare da utenti passivi
dell'ecosistema a suoi gestori
perché qui c'era tanta prevedibilità
portata dal mediterraneo ma non è
dappertutto così forse qualcuno di voi
ha visitato il messico e si è andato in
messico è probabile che abbia visitato
lo yucatan che la destinazione turistica
la più gettonata in yucatan sera per le
spiagge ma anche per dei siti
archeologici straordinari come ciccio e
nizza dove ci sono le piramide maya
beh ciccia inizia a ruota tutta intorno
a un altare di pietra dove si faceva una
cosa stranissima si mettevano a morte
ogni anno i vincitori dello scudetto e
mai avevano un loro sport piuttosto
delirante ma comunque i vincitori
annuali del torneo di questo sport
invece di ricevere in premio come i
nostri vincitori dello scudetto una
ferrari e una bella donna da cui
divorziare piacevole in premio divenire
adagiati su questa altari pietra ed
essere uccisi in maniera piuttosto
cruenta
se noi ci domandiamo ma cosa chiedevano
i maya gli dei per arrivare a tanto
con parole moderne risponderemo
l'equilibrio chiedevano che la pioggia
arrivasse al momento previsto che la
primavera sbocciasse al momento prevista
adesso la richiesta di fertilità gli dèi
esiste in tutte le civiltà ancora oggi
noi prima del raccolto facciamo le
professioni nei campi ma c'è una bella
differenza fra una processione e
squartare messi o cristiano urlando
perché i maya lo facevano perché erano
più cattivi di noi sicuramente no la
storia dimostra che gli europei sono
stati capaci di crudeltà inaudite
perché
perché la vida equilibrio non era così
abbondante se ne percepirà il valore
vedete il messico si trova nel bel mezzo
di una fluttuazione di cui avete sentito
parlare è il migno la nina
in questo alternarsi non c'era tanta
certezza di quando sarebbe arrivata la
primavera ed era così importante
che si arrivava a fare qualcosa come
mettere a morte
cristiano ronaldo ma insomma
l'importante che aveva che sia riuscito
a convincervi che l'equilibrio anche se
non ci pensiamo
e fondamentale ci sono riuscito dobbiamo
un istante capirli questo equilibrio
che dobbiamo assolutamente proteggere è
un equilibrio globale e globale
geograficamente
cosa significa significa che c'è un
residuo di effetto farfalla si il
battito delle ali di una farfalla tokyo
eccetera eccetera eccetera ma la fame di
un bambino in etiopia può essere il
primo evento di una serie di eventi che
può portare qualcuno a mettere una bomba
sull'aereo viaggiato e voi
è ormai sembra una nozione scontata
eppure abbiamo qualcosa dentro di noi
che ci impedisce veramente di renderla
operativa ci fa pensare in maniera
distorta
nel 2009 due psicologi della juta di
universi che hanno fatto un interessante
esperimento con i loro studenti li hanno
divisi in due gruppi hanno raccontato a
ciascun gruppo la stessa storia con una
variante
al primo gruppo hanno raccontato che
vivevano una città situata a 120 km da
una centrale nucleare che è esplosa
poi hanno proiettato immagini di fallout
del dopo esplosione eccetera secondo
gruppo esattamente la stessa cosa stessa
immagine ma nel racconto c'era una
piccola variante che hanno detto che
abitavano non a 120 chilometri ma a 40
chilometri da quella centrale che è
esplosa solo che questa si trovava oltre
il confine poi hanno misurato i livelli
d'ansia dei due gruppi per scoprire che
quello era stato detto che la centrale
di era esplosa in bocca ma oltre il
confine esprimevano un livello d'ansia
notevolmente minore rispetto agli altri
e questo ci porta a due possibili
conclusioni
la prima è che la utah university
insegna dei deficienti ma mi sembra
piuttosto improbabile perché erano dei
pc in psicologia la seconda è che anche
dei pc in psicologia anche chi fa
volontariato con legambiente persino io
che faccio questa cosa da 30 anni sono
sto attento sono prigioniero di
quest'idea che mi devo occupare soltanto
della mia isola che sono solo un isola
ma nessuno è un'isola noi resistiamo
anche un altro aspetto di questa
globalità dell'equilibrio che è la
globalità sistemica
geografica non possiamo avere
l'illusione di difendere l'equilibrio a
casa nostra dal caos che c'è fuori
magari con un muro sistemica non
possiamo avere l'illusione di difendere
l'equilibrio nel nostro settore quello
in cui lavoriamo quello in cui facciamo
impresa dal caos che c'è fuori tutto è
interconnesso ogni tanto io chiedo ai
miei studenti a bruciapelo di dirmi qual
è la prima cosa che viene in mente se
dico rivoluzione francese vengono fuori
varie risposte la più comune è maria
antonietta brioche
quale libro di testo dice che quattro
anni prima della rivoluzione francese
iniziato una eruzione in islanda nel
sistema il lucky questa intasato il
cielo di cenere le ceneri hanno bloccato
le radiazione solare questo ha
determinato tre inverni particolarmente
rigidi e quindi delle carestie ed è in
quel contesto lì che maria antonietta se
mai l'ha fatto ha parlato di pane o
brioche viviamo in un contesto in cui i
vulcani sono collegati con le
ghigliottine
l'equilibrio è fatto di tanti sotto
equilibri dobbiamo metterli sotto
controllo come facciamo beh sono tante
maniere ma la comunità internazionale ha
scelto una maniera che ci viene dalla
matematica che è una matrice cos'è una
matrice una tabella con tante caselle in
ogni casella e c'è un numero 5 una lista
di nomi numeri
diventa una matrice quando ciascuna
casella è collegata alle altre da un
algoritmo da una funzione che ci spiega
come un valore cambia al mutare
dell'altro allora vogliamo mettere sotto
controllo questo equilibrio di tante
isole che devono cooperare
possiamo immaginarci delle matrici a
diversi livelli di complessità per
esempio la matrice in cui c'è una
casella per il vulcano pinatubo in asia
che esplode collegata con una casella
che riguarda la produttività agricola in
asia che diminuisce collegata con una
casella sugli indici liri unipol street
che ne soffrono collegata con una
casella che riguarda mia zia peppa che
aveva investito tutta wall street perde
tutto e si suicida beh questo livello di
complessità non riusciamo a gestirlo
quindi ci dobbiamo rassegnare a qualcosa
di molto più semplice che è una matrice
a quattro caselle quella che vi presento
che mette in relazione ambiente pace e
diritti dell'uomo e sviluppo
come funziona
immaginiamoci un evento ambientare una
siccità in un rimane solo ambientale
diventa economico perché c'è un mancato
raccolto e se questo succede in un paese
ricco si ferma lì ma se succede in un
paese povero un mancato raccolto diventa
un problema di diritti umani perché fa
la differenza fra mandarono mandare i
propri figli a scuola ma prendete un
individuo una famiglia toglietegli la
sicurezza economica comprime te i suoi
diritti economici e cosa avete avete la
ricetta del conflitto perché questo
agricoltore cosa fa deve dare ancora da
mangiare ai suoi figli
il campo non produce più ha però c'è in
giro un datore di lavoro che paga lauti
stipendi per esempio se gli porti della
coca
dal quel paese fino in italia
illegalità privata oppure legalità
pubblica nel mio campo non produce più
niente ma cingere un datore di lavoro
che dagli stipendi molto grandi si
chiama boko haram formazione
terroristica e non sto raccontando una
favola e quello che sta succedendo
intorno al lago ciad noi siamo legati
così
questa matrice a quattro caselle
semplicissimo che vi mostro non è
nient'altro che armatrice di base del
nuovo progetto delle nazioni unite di
sviluppo tutti assieme tante caselle
tanti settori non sono più in
competizione l'uno che l'altro ciascuno
si realizza se realizziamo gli altri ed
è una vera rivoluzione che ci dà
speranza ma lasciatemi dire è come
funziona in pratica
questa una fascia di ghiacciai sono i
ghiacciai dell'himalaya hindu kush e
pamir fonderanno con riscaldamento
globale e se lo racconta in un salotto
di roma di milano mi guardano magari con
un po di compassione che peccato
perdiamo il la bellezza del paesaggio
alpino è vero è un grande valore ma ci
dimentichiamo che quando perdiamo un
elemento di questo equilibrio favoloso
perdiamo non solo la sua presenza e
bellezza ma anche la funzione che svolge
per mantenere tutto il resto
dell'equilibrio i ghiacciai di funzioni
in anno molte ma una è fondamentale per
gli esseri umani sono i regolatori di un
ordinato deflusso a valle delle acque se
qui gli acciai fondono
beh viene in un meccanismo con i caccia
year con un clima monsonico al sud c'è
una stagione molto umida che santerno la
stagione molto secca raccolgono
l'eccesso di umidità dell'estate e lo
ridistribuisca perdon della stagione
piovosa e lo ridistribuiscono durante la
stagione secca attraverso il reticolo di
fiumi che irrigano che a me dove sono
stanziate un miliardo e 400 milioni di
persone se gli acciai crollano a valle
devono gestire un ingestibile alternanza
di siccità ed alluvioni come faranno in
quella zona ci sono quattro stati che
hanno le bombe atomiche india cina
pakistan e russia questi si mettono a
litigare è un problema anche nostro
allora arrivata alla fine del mondo no
possiamo fare qualcosa perché siamo
isole ma nessuno è un'isola e da cosa
cominciamo bene cominciamo da noi stessi
ri mostro due triangoli il primo sica
piramide alimentare lo conosciamo tutti
ci dice come dobbiamo nutrirci per
essere in buona salute poca carne rossa
un po più di proteine ad altre fonti ma
soprattutto fibre vegetali beh succede
che sono i affianchiamo a questa
piramide la piramide l'impatto
sull'ambiente della produzione di
ciascuno di questi cibi scopriamo che
quanto più un certo cibo consumato in
eccesso e io non sono vegetariano fa
male a me tanto più la sua produzione fa
male
al pianeta all'ambiente diremmo
accidenti che coincidenza nel settore
alimentare noval in tutti i settori li
potete fare le stesse piramidi nelle
vostre scelte di trasporto individuale
scoprire che quanto più fatto una scelta
che gli lascia con salute
socializzazione soldi in tasca tanto più
è sostenibile ma cosa significa
significa vale la pena impegnarsi per la
sostenibilità ma significa anche che se
lo facciamo tutti assieme succede una
cosa la mia scelta di benessere
egoistico parto da me isola che vuole
essere in benessere si trasforma in
sostenibilità
ma cos'è la sostenibilità significa che
io rinuncio a quell eccesso che mi fa
male che non rimane nell'aria ma va
automaticamente ridistribuito a chi
invece ne ha bisogno quella hamburger di
troppo che a me fa male il sistema con
il tempo di spiegare perché lo
redistribuisce al bambino in africa che
invece ha bisogno di quelle proteine ma
allora cosa facciamo noi creiamo
l'equazione che risolve la matrice il
mio benessere la mia isola che si
riconosce
crea sostenibilità la sostenibilità crea
giustizia ma se noi abbiamo giustizia
nel mondo eliminiamo anche la causa di
quello che ci ha sempre afflitto e
andiamo a trovare quello che abbiamo
sempre cercato senza riuscire a
raggiungerlo cioè
la pace
siamo isole in un mondo di isole con una
regola non mostra vitate ha guidato vita
mea
ma con la regola dei tre moschettieri
tutti per uno uno per tutti grazie
[Applauso]